let me season the fish now yeah you know
what I mean know what sleeping bag these
rules as much noise are my shorts are
wet do you mind if I change into
something a little more comfy like this
loincloth loincloth 9 o'clock there we
go better build a fire Julie are you
chilly huh
can you sit next to me because I don't
have my blanket standard camping hey you
got a taste a bite of this hey guy let
me whoops let's taste of I let me let me
cover the fork so it doesn't spill open
slowly open there you go how good is
that it's a nice take your time take
your time and let the juice what's our
miso dressing on there I'd love some new
dress yeah can I sing you a song you
know this a happy night you all sing
western country western a lot of other
stuff oh wow well but I'm not doing a
fire in a kid is it a bowl of wine sure
is
I brought wait why is there a bottle of
wine in your guitar case well you know
what and here's the thing I can't drink
too much I'm Korean so I get very very
red I don't have the enzymes to break
down so I'm just gonna drink it that's
exactly right
all right get you applied up a little I
mean why don't we get you a relaxed and
have yourself a glass of wine there you
go you want to do a little too sweet no
do it wait I don't do coke table
experience stuff is real go fish in wine
you know what I do I cut it with my bro
cut it with hey bro coke fishing wine we
try [ __ ] I'm not doing anything of the
sort
what are you doing why are you pointing
your finger at me you got one finger
pointing to me but I see three fingers
pointed at you you must try to [ __ ] you
can't take it head one finger that's all
I'm saying
that's awesome Weinstein watch it's all
it is yeah so like I said I think he
doesn't do million we got a big guest hi
man I know you left sunglasses some [ __ ]
behind the studio but you know Tuesday
is my day man
I know I never been in this is so cool
all right man well yeah welcome big
break down
yeah listen all the time so this is
exciting
well yeah I mean you're coming you're
not really a guest bro you're not really
MMA experts oh wow I mean I know MMA so
it's an honor to be here yeah I guess
man but you said you're just getting
your glasses if you have questions well
let me look at the questions Oh weird
none for you I'm sorry man I thought
you're just getting your glasses and
kind of kicking rocks I started acting
when I was 20 hey man is it the Brian
breakdown no but they probably want to
know that I'm also gonna be in Utah this
weekend it wise guys they hope they know
that I'm not trying to hide I'm not
trying to hijack your audience and then
you can be in you mean San Francisco
Cobbs sucking pipe don't say that on
your show cuz I have no recourse I'm
just excited to be here I guess man but
you kind of hijacked the show because
you said you had to come and get I had
sunglasses here or something and then
your I just thought I'd take this
opportunity this I know but you're in
training gear I know but I just want to
take this opportunity to say train hard
and read a lot all right man whoa you're
young stay in school okay well thanks
for that message welcome what so this is
it huh this is it you sit there I sit
here so when we do our show you sit
there and now nothing that's changed I
feel like I'm on our show but I'm not
because this is your show yeah I getting
fight what can I do an impression of you
I'm Brennan fighting talk this is
fighting a submission hold on what man
well I have a question yes what
[ __ ] what the easy now hey you're my
studio it's too is that's my own
figurine that my boy Sean Sweeney made
that's a big look at the gucci boots you
bring that out know the fans bit brah
you you bring that out when you do big
brand you like I'm not doing with Bryan
anymore
um it's me and there's my [ __ ] you
didn't make a broad one you look like a
bride walking you look like it exactly
look like an Egyptian tradition from the
from the 20s will do see the Gucci just
grab do you well i'd i swear to god oh
my god oh well that's broke down it's
over now making wow curry wolf [ __ ] man
[ __ ] hump you were really hard on
that so that's what you would look like
if you lost your legs in africa no no in
a Trombley rule head dude
sorry that's a better look for you you
know what I'm out that you leave now why
why you broke my figurine how was I
thinking in the middle of the show
you're the worst guest he came in here
you broke my gut sorry
sorry left is give you booze hahaha
that's all you care about anyway that's
how there is just your gucci boots so
what's better is almost better how dare
you though i'm sorry i just came in
through everything on the china shop I'm
sorry love just leave man huh
get out of here see you later I had a
check-up when I was a young man and my
doctor was this Stern it was in
Connecticut I'll never forget it I was
probably in high school I might have
been as playing college or just after
and he was this Stern New England
Puritan just a tall stern man and in New
England and Connecticut especially he's
changing now but there was a formality
there was a very strong English
influence it was a formality to things
and a doctor would come in check me out
he said yes
are you having unprotected sex holy I
was probably 20 maybe 19 knology
unprotected sex and I was like oh this
is very awkward
well first of all doctor answer is 100%
and of course in fact I don't believe in
condoms and of course I will do that for
the rest of my life
yes meanwhile I was like never I sure
did I didn't want him to stick in a
cotton swab up my dong have you have you
begun to get tested your hands and they
asked you for all the stuff and you're
like but you're there to solve a problem
but you find yourself a lying oh yeah
how many sexual partners have you had in
the past three months like yes will you
try to go through it but you still like
dirt bags and still like dirt bags so as
many as I can sir as many as I can it's
a full-time do you think so folks are
exhausted I barely got a better get here
I [ __ ] so much exhausted all the time
my balls are always empty I just need
you to give me the goddamn medication
and get rid of this runny dude that's
right do we have to go over this yep
I'm a reoccurring customer I can tell
you I don't need to test tell you right
now I'm 100% positive for whatever I've
been around this block enough where I
don't need you to inspect me a question
got the clap sir just God and give me
those [ __ ] pills so I can get that on
a piece I made the walk I need you just
give me my goddamn the scripts I get out
of here
matter of fact I'm a VIP member of this
club my friend my friend cause Brian
Brian what is [ __ ] what I got warts
oh I as we're not good I said show me
your dick I can't were there warts off
show me your dick now yeah he had he had
never heard of any war oh that's dope
that is very prevalent warts yeah or the
old war tolas are that's I don't think
so be I think in the older generation
not in these days you're worse than the
most common they are the most common
they are they yeah I remember when my
buddy did it and I said to my to my
doctor I go can you check me I didn't
know I was so paranoid you know and he's
like oh they're epidemic
yeah but I was good I was good